la pire des choses serait de rouvrir
trop vite trop fort et d'être ensuite
amené à refermer
c'est ce que déclarait emmanuel macron
il y a quelques semaines au sujet des
lieux de culte il devait d'ailleurs
restée fermée jusqu'à nouvel ordre mais
le conseil d'état on a décidé autrement
et saisi par plusieurs associations est
la plus haute juridiction administrative
a estimé que cette interdiction portait
une atteinte grave et manifestement
illégale à la liberté de culte
elle s'est donc dans un décret publié au
journal officiel
la nuit dernière que le gouvernement
autorise la reprise des cérémonies
religieuses mais en suivant des règles
strictes respect des gestes barrières
distanciation physique port du masque ou
encore désinfection des mains une
réouverture qui satisfait ici les
nombreux fidèles de la paroisse de notre
dame de grâce à paris où s'est déroulée
ce samedi la première messe en public
depuis le 16 mars
c'est la première depuis deux mois
franchement merci mon dieu de nous avoir
rassemblé les distances étaient bonnes
et on entendait bien de partout le
prêche et vraiment ça fait du bien de
revenir à l'église très heureux de
pouvoir enfin vivre la messe et les
sacrements ensemble et c'était une vraie
joie vraiment quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et se dire que le
seigneur il est n'est pas seulement
c'est pas seulement un esprit mais c'est
quelqu'un de vivant c'est un cétacé pas
seulement un esprit mais c'est une
personne vivante et que chaque jour nous
manquer de le retrouver et la deux pour
enfants s'y approcher ça nous fait du
bien et ça nous a fait très très plaisir
de revoir les gens en vrai tout le
confinement nous nous étions adressé à
eux via des vidéos des moyens de
substitution et puis la revoir en vrai
les jambes c'est vraiment ce qu'il nous
fallait
ils nous ont beaucoup manqué aussi on
est ravi de les revoir
évidemment il ya toutes les consignes
sanitaires qui sont nécessaires et qui
continuent à nous mettre quelques bâtons
dans les roues mais voilà
par rapport à la joie qu'on a de revoir
de se revoir tous les uns les autres
parce que ça fait partie vraiment de
notre manière de vivre le culte nous les
chrétiens de vivre ensemble cette joie
dépasse tous ces accompagne la fête de
pâques qu'ont vu les quelques semaines
le ministère de l'intérieur prévient
malgré tout si toutes les mesures
sanitaires ne sont pas respectées elles
les préfets de département pourront
interdire l'ouverture ou ordonné la
fermeture d'un lieu de culte à côté
musulman est les fidèles célèbrent
demain la fin du mois du ramadan et
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire de
nombreux imams ont appelé à éviter tout
risque de contamination et donc
d'exercer la prière de l'aïd el fitr à
la maison